donc je voulais dit au menu du voyage
que valéry giscard d'estaing vente
reprendre demain et vendredi en alsace
et en lorraine un plat de résistance le
développement des responsabilités locke
dans son livre le président demandait
qu'une loi fondamentale détermine les
véritables compétences de l'état des
départements et des communes et
parallèlement pendant un an sous la
présidence d'olivier guichard qui
n'était pas encore ministre d'état une
commission se penchait sur cette réforme
communale un titre vivre ensemble un
état d'esprit dépasser les querelles de
clocher il ya plus de trente six mille
clochers en france chacun symbolisant
une commune
la commune est la première cellule
administrative la base même de la vie
démocratique
trop souvent la vie de ses habitants a
été marquée par les décisions venues
d'en haut c'est à dire de paris cette
grand-mère a vu sa commune changer ses
petits enfants quand ils n'oseront plus
hobby la connaîtront déjà transformé
serez 36000 communes il y en a qui sont
calmes le temps paraît si être arrêté
certaines communes ont très peu
d'habitants et des moyens financiers
réduits parfois tout à côté on trouve
des communes qui se développe rapidement
les bâtiments modernes et poussent comme
des champignons
la commission d'étude qui était présidée
par olivier guichard propose de rendre
l'initiative locale aux communes et
départements et les régions
assumant ce qui ne peut être fait à la
base mettre en commun certains besoins
et aussi certains moyens telle est un
des objectifs proposés pour y parvenir
ils seraient créés 3600 communauté de
communes et 750 communauté urbaine sorte
de fédération communale elle
s'occuperait de l'urbanisme la
délivrance des permis de construire par
exemple de l'implantation des zones
d'activités comme les zones
industrielles ou bien encore du
ramassage en commun des ordures
ménagères
la commune aurait toujours en charge
l'organisation des élections
on est l'état civil notamment toutes ces
propositions qui bouleverserait la vie
administrative française sont contenues
dans un volumineux rapport son titre
évocateur vivre ensemble dans les
responsabilités qui nous avait été
donnée par le président de la république
quand il a constitué cette commission ça
va bientôt faire un an d'ailleurs il y
avait tout à la fois l'idée de re
découvrir les responsabilités locales
mais aussi tout de même de bien préciser
où étaient les pouvoirs c'est à dire qui
fait quoi
la compétence locale c'est à dire celle
de la commune et parfois du département
s'exercerait dans trois domaines le
premier comprend l'éducation scolaire
l'action sanitaire et l'action
culturelle deuxième domaine concerne
l'action économique et les équipements
d'intérêt professionnel
enfin le troisième englobe l'aménagement
l'urbanisme des transports et la voirie
qui seraient traitées uniquement à
l'échelon local et à conserverait tout
ce qui est d'importance nationale
notamment la diplomatie et la dépend
bien évidemment tout ce qui relève d'une
politique économique nationale comme
l'organisation à l'échelle territoire et
ptt ou bien de la navigation aérienne
des transports ferroviaires et des
autres jours
en ce qui concerne le financement au
niveau des communes une nouvelle
répartition s'établirait les communes
percevrait la taxe d'habitation l'impôt
foncier bâti et non bâti et la
communauté de commune recevrait le
produit de la taxe professionnelle
et puis il y aurait des dotation
d'équipement et ça je crois que c'est la
grande innovation de la rive d'olt
tactiquement c'est à dire que la commune
c'est chaque année ce qu'elle a à
consacrer comme dépenses d'équipement
provenant de l'état et ça veut dire
qu'elle choisit elle fait une piscine où
elle fait une école où elle fait autre
chose
elle choisit ses priorités sans avoir à
en référer à personne oui justement ces
élus locaux qui décrochait à paris des
subventions par l'intervention
personnelle est un bon argument
électoral croyez vous qu'ils sont prêts
à accepter cette réforme
le maire qui n'aura plus à faire cette
quête permanente et un petit peu
fatigante et qui pourra se consacrer à
l'organisation de la vie collective dans
sa commune croyez-moi il souhaite que ça
les communes auraient donc davantage
d'argent et le président de la
république a qualifié ces propositions
de révolution tranquille
dans l'opposition on formule plusieurs
critiques
la première les syndics de communautés
de communes ne serait pas élu au
suffrage universel comme les maires la
seconde ces propositions mettront du
temps à être appliquée en effet la
réforme ne serait pas effective avant
enfin l'opposition pose la question
existe-t-il une volonté politique qui
bouleverse et traditions d'une france
qui depuis toujours
regarde vers paris et comme tous les
maires nous sommes preneurs d'une
réforme
je dis bien profondes jusqu'à présent
nous a toujours répondu que la réforme
était en cours et on voit très bien
qu'elle ne marche pas puisque la simple
réforme la taxe professionnelle provoque
les remous que vous connaissez et on
nous a toujours répondu pendant 20 ans
monsieur giscard d'estaing le premier
monsieur focale ensuite que c'était ça
la réforme
tout d'un coup on dit qu'on va faire
autre chose moi je ne demande pas mieux
qu'à le croire
je dirais que c'est un bon rapport que
les gens qui l'ont établi ont bien
travaillé
c'est un bon apport conservateur mais je
sais que je connais des pratiques du
gouvernement depuis 20 ans me fait
douter de la capacité des gouvernements
conservateurs d'appliquer de tels
récents
ce n'est pas avant les élections
municipales que le parlement sera
officiellement saisi du rapport richard
mais déjà que les présidents de groupe
de l'assemblée en ont reçu un exemplaire
et de nombreux élus parce qu'ils sont
également maire d'une commune étudie ses
propositions dans les jours qui viennent
olivier guichard sera entendu par la
commission des lois du sénat
les questions qui lui seront posées
seront probablement nombreuses car il ne
s'agit pas dans ses propositions de
mesures techniques mais de favoriser un
nouveau pouvoir en france un pouvoir
local est d'abord communal touristes à
strasbourg
valéry giscard d'estaing traitera
surtout des collectivités locales un
discours que nous retransmettront en
direct vendredi à partir de 11h30 et
puis ça